is bowl game week here in vegas and
before the nfl celebrates some of its
best players this weekend we get to
support some of the country's strongest
patients i stopped by allegion stadium
today to learn more about the east west
shrine bowl check it out
we are here at allegiance stadium for
the east west shrine bowl it is the 97th
year of the largest college all-star
football game in the world not just the
country in the world okay so we're here
with mel who's from shriner's children
first and foremost how does it feel to
be in las vegas for the first time this
year well for the game it's great to be
here in las vegas at allegiance stadium
part of nfl's pro bowl week we we
couldn't be more excited it's a great
way to celebrate our 100th anniversary
of shriners children's that is
incredible you guys do amazing work for
children just give us an introduction to
what shriners children is all about sure
founded in 1922 as a response to the
polio epidemic in the united states it's
now pivoted and we take care of spinal
cord injuries orthopedic issues burn
care for pediatric patients we've served
over 1.5 million children from 170
countries around the world incredible
and that brings me to our ambassadors
here our shriners children's ambassador
sydney and seth you know how has shiners
changed your life
i can't even explain how they changed my
life i had a very invasive surgery which
has changed my life for the better and
now i get to come to these amazing
events and speak about the care that
shriners have it's the most amazing care
anywhere beautiful seth what does it
feel like to be here at a legion in
vegas celebrating this bowl today it's
awesome i mean i love getting to meet
all these players and get to getting to
represent shriners and what we do who we
are and represent all the millions of
patients who have been treated with
shiners absolutely and mel you know what
does this mean for the players who are
involved to see these children and to do
the watchmen challenges well you know we
say it's more than just a game because
we're celebrating these college
all-stars before they make it big and go
to the pros but it's really about our
patients and so being able to see them
this morning interact to do some
physical challenges together i think
gives the players some insight into some
of the challenges they face every day
absolutely and it's like you said it's
all about your patience and the game
tomorrow benefits your patience so tell
everybody how they can get involved in
and come down and enjoy it absolutely
we'd love to have everyone join us
tickets are still available at
shrinebowl.com
and it's gonna be an amazing game as we
see these players that we call today's
all-stars and tomorrow's legends oh
that's beautiful okay you guys i think
it's time to do a little watching me
challenge what do you think let's do it
hi i'm carter from las vegas yes
zakopie i'm from georgia georgia all
right coaches you ready tell us what
we're doing
so you're going to balance on one leg
for 10 seconds and then when i say go
you're going to hop don't let your foot
touch the ground and put on a jersey and
whoever wins is the ultimate winner and
we want to see your touchdown dances at
the end okay let's do this okay
okay start holding holding
okay
you got it okay
three
two one go let's go go carter there you
go there we go there you go don't let
your foot touch the ground wait a minute
let's go let's go let's go
let's go
i think it was a
let's do time
touchdown dances let's see all right
touch the dance
what's your dance
great job guys
get it carter
it was so fun over there thank you to
shriners children's for sponsoring that
segment check out the game tomorrow the
big game at allegion stadium for tickets
and more information just head to
shrinebull.com you know i think it was
your jersey on inside out so i mean
technically i would give the win to
carter
no carter wins regardless
yes great game great cause you can't go
wrong with that can i get a little
touchdown dance though oh if i scored a
touchdown
i would have a touchdown fate because i
scored a touchdown like
did it look mom and dad i scored a
touchdown i like that
touchdown faint that would be the first
touchdown faint collapse
i would collapsibly you know i played
high school football real quick okay i
caught the balls nothing but end zone in
front of me all i could do was run i was
so excited i caught the ball my knees
gave out and i collapsed
so embarrassing so the touchdown faint
has